en direct ben shemie en direct de
l'hôpital européen georges pompidou à
paris
bonsoir des scènes des mesures de
freinage sont mis en place depuis
maintenant le 20 mars sur tout le
territoire
où en sommes nous effectivement
stéphanie plus de deux semaines après
ces fameuses mesures de freinage mise en
place par le gouvernement pour sortir de
cette troisième vague du coronavirus en
france la situation stagne toujours
alors qu'on atteint bientôt le chiffre
fatidique des 100 mille morts est kamal
belle macro a fait à ce matin son
conseil de défense sanitaire son énième
conseil de défense sanitaire afin de
trouver la stratégie la plus appropriée
pour sortir rapidement de cette
situation bien sûr certains éléments
sont venus perturber la stratégie du
gouvernement notamment cette question et
ce problème du vaillant brésilien jean
castex a annoncé que des mesures plus
strictes à être mise en place avec ce
pays notamment au niveau est des
déplacements et puis bien sûr il ya eu
le lancement très controversé et
contrariant du vaccin johnson and
johnson le gouvernement doit donc faire
face à ces nouveaux contretemps pour
pouvoir sortir de cette crise cette
sortie de crise qui est prévu comme
emmanuel macron lavanant c'est à partir
de mi-mai d'avril atta le porte parole
du gouvernement de son côté annoncé
qu'un hommage national sera rendu à
toutes les victimes du corona virus
jeudi à partir de 18 heures le chef de
l'état réunira certains membres du
gouvernement afin de réexaminer ce
processus de sortie crise et de
réouverture notamment des bars des
restaurants et des lieux culturels
une échéance qui malgré tout reste en
danger au vu du nombre de patients
toujours en réanimation on en compte
plus de 6000 est la question que tout le
monde se pose évidemment la vaccination
va t-elle pour voir enfin accéléré
là effectivement stéphanie le
gouvernement table vraiment sur cette
campagne vaccinale afin de sortir de
cette situation il a annoncé que les
vaccins et cette vaccination allait
s'accélérer
semaine après semaine le porte parole du
gouvernement gabrel attal a assuré que
plus de 200 mille doses de vaccin
johnson & johnson seront disponibles et
bien sûr a administré aux patients de
plus de 55 ans dans des les plus brefs
délais concernant le vaccin astrazeneca
qui fait parler de lui dont certains
pays européens l'ont interdit
définitivement comme le danemark le
gouvernement français lui a annoncé
qu'il avait confiance en ce vaccin une
confiance et une déclaration qui a été
appuyée bien sûr par la haute autorité
de santé concernant le vaccin bio ntech
et puis finder l'union européenne
annoncé qu'il y aura une livraison de
plus de 50 millions de doses sur
l'ensemble du territoire européen et
bien sûr pour la france je vous propose
d'écouter concernant ces vaccins le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent
nous avons reçu la première livraison de
vaccins de gens de scène c'est à dire
200 mille doses qui sont arrivés en
début de semaine sur notre territoire et
qui sont en train d'être acheminée
auprès de la médecine de ville et des
officines de pharmacie je crois que il
l'aura été entièrement acheminés
jeudi ou vendredi ce vaccin a bénéficié
des autorisations de la part des agences
de santé européennes et françaises et
donc à ce stade ce vaccin va évidemment
être distribuée est administré dans les
mêmes conditions que ce qui est prévu
aujourd'hui pour le vaccin
astrazeneca c'est à dire pour les
personnes âgées de plus de 55 ans alors
vous l'aurez compris cette stratégie
vaccinale reste larmes première est
préférable du gouvernement afin de
sortir de cette crise sanitaire et de
cette troisième vague et de coronavirus
aujourd'hui on compte un patient sur
cinq et qui a reçu cette dose de vaccin
7 % des patients eux ont reçu les deux
doses de vaccin depuis le lancement de
cette campagne vaccinale le gouvernement
table sur plus de 20 millions de
vaccinés d'ici à au 15 mai ce qui pourra
permettre au gouvernement de suivre sa
ligne de conduite est de sortir
progressivement de cette crise avec bien
sûr l'annoncé d'une réouverture à partir
de mi-mai annoncée par le gouvernement
et par emmanuel macron et comme je
voulais rappeler cette sortie de crise
reste bien sûr à discuter au vu de la
situation stagnante et de cette campagne
de vaccination qui a pris du retard sur
l'ensemble du territoire
merci ben hassen chébili en direct de
l'hôpital européen georges pompidou